was america founded as a christian
nation in your view what if we look at
the declaration of independence what are
the words mean
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
it seems like god is breathing through
those words too yeah i think so you know
the founders will be some kind of
combination of of deism um certainly
christianity is is coming up through
them enlightenment rationalism all in
kind of a mix you know so you're not
going to find in our founding fathers
simply thomas aquinas or like a purely
you know classically christian
understanding it's christianity
in in those various expressions because
actually i would see the enlightenment
as a sort of
child of christianity we could talk
about that but
having said all that yes i think they
are expressing
at least the residue of a once deeply
integrated christian sense of things
that uh
our rights are not created by the
government they're not uh uh doled out
by the government they come from god and
and the other thing i find really
interesting is equality because um
look in classical philosophy political
philosophy plato aristotle cicero
it's not equality for them it's our
inequality that's really interesting
so plato divides us into these three
classes and aristotle says only a tiny
little coterie of property males of
sufficient education should be in the
political life the rest should all be in
private life you know and then some are
suited for slavery so i mean he divides
us dramatically same with cicero and so
on um
where does this come from this weird
idea that we're all
equal i mean how we're not equal in
beauty not equal in strength we're not
equal in moral attainment we're not
equal in
intelligence so what is it and i think
the residue especially comes through in
that little word that all men are
created equal
that's our equality that we're all
equally children of god so take god out
of the picture i think
we are going to slide rapidly into
an embrace of inequality now in the
classical world yes
but heck look at the 20th century i mean
when god is excluded in a very
systematic way
i think you saw the suspension of rights
and the suspension of equality like mad
so i think it's very important
that god is in the picture and that
we're a nation under god it matters
enormously that's not pious boilerplate
that's at the at the rational
foundations of our democracy
you